[Musik]
das heimatliche heimatfest der volks
heimat mit monika gruber zum heimatfest
der volkswirt ist das nicht herrlich
liebe freunde an den heimatlichen
empfangsgeräten das wort heimat ist
zurück endlich sind heimatgefühle wieder
erlaubt bei uns in der deutschen heimat
immer das heimatgefühl aber noch nie
verboten habe ich bin heimat das war ein
schlimmes pulver sowie wie vor hart
verengung das wollte keiner in den mund
nehmen aber das ist jetzt vorbei heute
leben wir heimat heute haben wir endlich
wieder eine union die eine union die
stolz ist auf unser deutschland und die
heimat einfach lädt die eben weiß was
heimat bedeutet für heimat über heimat
nach heimat nach geborgenheit
geborgenheit der heimat heimat und
heimann hat mal jemand was zu trinken
[Applaus]
wissenschaftler der markus söder
universität haben jetzt herausgefunden
je öfter man heimat sagt desto weniger
leute weil die af deckt ist doch
schwachsinn weiter bitte ist auch
richtig so verkopft der stadt nicht sie
heimat es ist viel mehr als ein ort es
ist ein gefühl gerade auf dem land da
kommt ja so viel zusammen
die heimatliche gerüche die wärme die
geborgenheit das wolle die menschen hier
griffen scholle heimat hatte ich schon
einmal da sind ja ganz kurz ganz gut
aber einfach nur ständig heimat creme
reicht auch nicht
diese alte u den wir zum präsidenten
gemacht haben hat jetzt ständig kalender
sprüche raus heimat ist der ort an dem
das wir bedeutung bekommt wer sich nach
heimat sind der ist nicht von gestern
heimat gibt es auch im plural
ja klar
[Applaus]
das soll in der flora sein heil werte
oder heimat
wenn unsere politiker neudorf heimische
stieg in die erste mal mit investieren
in die heimat gerade auf dem land damit
ist er wieder ärzte gibt oder eine post
in vielen dörfern hält ja nicht mal mehr
einen bus warum denn auch wenn es da so
schön ist da brauche ich auch keinen bus
der hmi weg bringt sie verstehen das
landleben einfach nicht diese
verschworene gemeinschaft wo hinter
jeden kennt wo der ministrant morgens
zärtlich den pfarrer weg muss noch werte
gibt
dann muss ich sagen bin ich doch lieber
stadtmensch stadt ist auch heimat auf
jede heimat kann man stolz sein
die dortmunder zum beispiel die sind
stolz auf ihr bier die kölner auf ihrem
kamen die nürnberger auf ihre rostbraten
stunden oder java sind echt weltkrieg
bielefeld viele väter können sie stolz
sein auf
ist auch egal monika gruber
[Applaus]